president Trump celebrates his birthday
with historically good economy we talk
over president Trump's comments about
Kim jong-un plus the Department of
Justice Inspector General report on
James Comey is breaking and will talk
about it this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
I'll get really busy Newsday today I
mean a lot of news breaking like right
now and we will go through all of it in
just a second but first I want to talk
to you a little bit about the fact that
you need some money right look I know
that you probably have something that
you want to do some work around the
house can pay off some credit card bills
and you need some sort of short-term
loan you need some sort of swing loan
that is going to make you able to get
through the next couple of weeks or pay
for that project that you've been
putting off well that's what Lending
Club is for with Lending Club you can
consolidate your debt pay off your
credit cards with one fixed monthly
payment since 2007 Lending Club is how
millions of people regain controlled
their finances with affordable
fixed-rate personal loans you don't have
to go to a bank and there's no high
interest credit cards you just go to
Lending Club com let me tell them about
yourself and how much you want to borrow
pick the terms that are right for you
and if you're approved your loan is
automatically deposited into your bank
account in as little as a few days
they're the number one peer-to-peer
lending platform over thirty five
billion dollars in loans issued all you
have to do to check them out is go over
to Lending Club com /ban you can
actually check your rate in minutes and
borrow up to $40,000 and again these are
gonna be lower rates than getting a high
interest credit card for sure Lending
Club com /ban that's Lending Club com
/ban again all loans met by made by web
bank member FDIC Equal Housing lender
check it out Lending Club com slash Ben
to see if you're qualified for a known
that that it's quick and easy and and
available to you Lending Club comm slash
Ben go check it out for loans up to
$40,000 alrighty so let's talk a little
bit about the fact the president okay so
it's president from birthday today's
president comes birthday and president
Trump is 72 years old today which is
pretty amazing I mean the guy is the
oldest president ever elected and he is
fit as a fiddle and ready for lovin
president Trump is obviously an
energetic dude and he's celebrating a
good birthday I mean let's let's be real
about this the President of the United
States is is having himself in upswing
in the polls and there are a lot of
elements where the president looks
really good so the this is a great story
for him today the Federal Reserve's just
raised its outlook on u.s. economic
growth on Wednesday the median real GDP
forecast Rose rose to 2.8 percent up
from 2.7 percent for this year there are
no changes for 2019 and 2020 economic
activity has been rising at a solid
right according to the Fed statement
marking an upgrade from moderate in the
previous statement also there is a
report out today put out by
Jim Pathak Lucas all about how the there
are banks that were now revising the
growth estimates for the last quarter up
dramatically all the way up to four
percent from two point eight percent and
what we are seeing here is a booming
economy this is the quote from JP Morgan
actually on the heels of this data we
now estimate real GDP is expanding at a
4.0 annual rate in q2 up from our prior
estimate of 2.75 almost twice the 2.2
percent growth rate experienced in q1
I'm old enough to remember when it was
considered crazy when President Trump
suggested that he was going to get the
annual growth rate up to four or five
percent of GDP and now what's happening
right now it appears to be happening so
that is great news for the President of
the United States obviously the North
Korean summit is also very good news for
the presidents of the United States at
least in terms of public relations the
public is very happy that President
Trump did this they think that maybe
just maybe this will open us up to a new
world we'll talk a little bit about that
in a bit what it is that that is being
opened up here whether in fact President
Trump has open negotiations that will
lead to denuclearization of the North
Korean Peninsula or whether what we are
really talking about is another sort of
plan that president from has in my know
and talked about that in a little while
plus in sort of hilarious news you
recall that President Obama spent an
inordinate amount of time attempting to
bring the World Cup to the United States
so he cut a video in 2009 he talked with
Sepp Blatter who's the head at that
point of five of the World Cup about
bringing the World Cup to the United
States in I believe he's 2022 well now
it turns out that the administration
that got it done is actually the Trump
administration now the Trump
administration was involved in sort of
covert ways right in quiet ways but they
put together what's called the United
bit the United bid was a bid for the
World Cup between Canada China Canada
Mexico and the United States and that
group is going to host some 80 World Cup
games the vote past so they are going to
host the World Cup 60 of those games
will be held in the United States 60 of
those matches now I am NOT a soccer fan
so I really don't care all that much but
it is a thumb in the eye to the Obama
administration that spent years trying
to woo the World Cup to the United
States and then President Trump gets it
done in the first year and a half so
that's that's pretty hilarious
and you have to enjoy that so President
Trump is having himself a good birthday
adding to that good birthday is the fact
that the Department of Justice Inspector
General report just released a report
blasting James Comey for violating FBI
protocol during the Hillary Clinton
investigation now this is a report
that's going to be interpreted
a couple of different ways it's going to
be interpreted in the worst possible
light for the FBI by Republicans and the
best possible light for but for the FBI
by Democrats here's what the report
actually says so on Thursday Bloomberg
News got the early scoop on the DOJ
inspector general's report on the
actions of the FBI during the 2016
election cycle with regard to the
investigation into Hillary Clinton's
misuse of her email server so according
to Bloomberg the reports conclusion from
Inspector General Michael Horowitz you
remember this guy is the same one who
recommended the prosecution of former
deputy FBI director Andrew McCabe for
leaking information in an authorized
fashion to the Pres so he has a pretty
good track record of calling things out
when he sees them he says that James
Comey and the FBI violated protocol but
did not do so for reasons of political
bias and this is where the Republicans
are going to be spitting man what they
are going to say is that of course James
Comey operated by breaking protocol in
terms of political bias and the left is
going to say the same thing by the way
they're gonna say that the FBI violated
protocol in order to make Hillary lose
the election every boy every buddy's
going to attribute to James coming in
the FBI political bias I think there is
political bias but not quite in the way
that people think the political bias
works so people think political bias
means that combing elect Hillary or
combing like Trump I don't think that's
the political bias at work here I think
the political bias at work is that James
Comey wanted to exonerate Hillary
Clinton knowing that that's what the DOJ
wanted him to do and at the same time he
didn't want the FBI slandered with the
idea that the FBI had been ordered by
the DOJ to clear the the the clear-all
of this or they also didn't want the DOJ
to look corrupt so instead he took it on
his own shoulders
I think the commis are an explanation of
his event of these events is damning
enough I don't think you have to make up
another explanation for why it is that
Jim's coming violated protocol here's
what the the the DOJ report concludes
the IG report concludes quote well we
did not find that these decisions were
the result of political bias on commis
part we nevertheless concluded that by
departing so clearly and dramatically
from FBI and department norms the
decisions negatively impacted the
perception of the FBI and the department
as fair administrators of justice so
here is what Michael Horowitz claims he
says the James Comey had troublingly
failed to inform the Department of
Justice in advance about his July 5th
statement condemning Clinton for
carelessness but absolving her of
criminal activity so in other words
James Comey had been told by Loretta
Lynch that she would basically accept
his recommendation instead of him going
to Loretta Lynch
with his recommendation quietly and then
learn a Lynch announcing everything he
went out there and he did his famous
July 5th press conference where he
basically announced that Hillary was
guilty but he wasn't going to recommend
prosecution for her anyway because she
didn't have requisite intent even though
the law itself does not need intent the
law is written along lines of negligence
it is not written along lines of Hillary
Clinton must have wanted to expose
classified information to foreign
sources but James Comey added that
elements of law and then he said later
that we wouldn't prosecute anybody under
these same circumstances which is sort
of a dicey proposition Michael Horowitz
says that the big problem here is not
the actual statement that Comey made
it's that James Comey did not coordinate
with Loretta Lynch on all of this yeah
it's a little bit weak men Horowitz said
that commis failure to coordinate with
the DOJ involved a quote troubling lack
of any direct substantive communication
with Lynch Horowitz added that Comey
also should have coordinated with
Loretta Lynch before sending his October
28th 2016 letter to Congress announcing
the reopening of the Hillary email
investigation based on the discoveries
on Anthony Weiner's computer here's what
Horowitz writes quote we found it
extraordinary that in advance of to such
consequential decisions the FBI director
decided that the best course of conduct
most do not speak directly and
substantively with the Attorney General
about how best to navigate those
decisions now Comey will say the reason
I didn't talk to Loretta Lynch is cuz I
thought Loretta Lynch might be corrupt
she'd met on the tarmac with Bill
Clinton the right will say the reason
that Comey didn't coordinate with
Loretta Lynch on all this is because he
didn't want to look her up but he
actually was corrupt he knew what
Loretta Lynch wanted and he gave it to
her so both sides are gonna read this
report the way they want to read this
report Horowitz also investigated
anti-trump text messages between the FBI
agents Peter struck and Lisa Paige
remember there were all these anti-trump
text messages during the campaign about
how much they disliked Trump and
Horowitz found there was quote no
documentary or testimonial evidence that
improper considerations including
political bias directly affected these
specific investigative actions we
reviewed now it's worth noting that is
pretty weak legal language there right
that's a little bit of lawyer fudging
right there when he says that there's no
evidence that improper considerations
including political bias quote directly
affected the specific investigative
actions
how about indirectly affected these
specific investigative actions what if
it's not that they decided they were
gonna get Trump overtly but they decide
they were gonna be a little harder on
President Trump or a little bit easier
on Hillary Clinton cuz they didn't like
President Trump right that's a little
bit of wiggle room in the language
Horowitz said the contact by these
employees did cast a doubt over the
entire FBI investigation so as I say
it's easy to look at this report and see
how Republicans come to the conclusion
that Comey acted politically how
Democrats come to the conclusion that
Comey acted politically because after
all Comey did more damage to Hillary
Clinton than he did to Donald Trump
during the during the campaign itself i
coming to tremendous damage to donald
trump after the campaign once trump was
president but commis real damaging
impact during the campaign itself was
actually anti-hillary every was the
reopening the investigation in late
october the damaged hillary clinton you
know right about the time that she
needed a surge in the polls and instead
she faded in the polls so dramatically
the chins up losing the election so
democrats are gonna claim that the
report is biased Republicans are already
claiming that the report is biased there
are a bunch of Republican Congress
people who have put out a letter to the
director of the Inspector General of the
DOJ asking for drafts of the report they
want to make sure that it was not
watered down so here is what Andy Biggs
Ron DeSantis and Matt gets right they
say we are concerned that during this
time people may have changed the report
in a way that obfuscates your findings
per Congress's oversight authority we
request you supply our original drafts
along with the final published form
unfortunately over the past year the DOJ
has repeatedly fought requests by
Congress to produce documents related to
this investigation and when the DOJ
actually provided documents the
materials have been heavily redacted
past and present DOJ officials have
asserted security concerns even though
the documents we have seen do not
legitimately contain these issues with
every confidence your investigation and
report has been thorough and accurate we
request the various draft so they want
the draft of the report they think the
Jeff Sessions and Rod Rosenstein over at
the DOJ had some sort of impact on
Michael Horowitz his final report in
this Inspector General report I don't
blame them for being suspicious after
all sessions and Rosenstein have not
been forthcoming with documents that
have been subpoenaed by Congress at the
same time I don't really blame the DOJ
for being suspicious of Republican
Congress people who've been leaking as
much as they can to the press at the
first available opportunity and
sometimes taking things out of context
this is why I've been saying for a long
time President Trump should just
declassify everything he can possibly
declassify the President of the United
States does have the executive authority
does he classify as many materials as he
wishes there in the executive branch I
want to see all of them I want to get to
the bottom of this I think everyone else
does too and I think that these
secondhand reports are not nearly as
useful as our ability to peruse the
documentation ourselves okay so in just
a second I wanna talk about another
of breaking news that is not as good for
president Trump's this IG report is
pretty decent for president trumpets as
Comey miss acted badly that's gonna be
enough for president from to go after
him there's a piece of bad news for
president Trump I want to talk about in
just a second first I want to say thanks
to our sponsors over at dynatrap so
summertime is officially upon us and the
only thing more annoying than Nancy
Pelosi and Chuck Schumer and the
mainstream media are flies and
mosquitoes and other insects invading
your home as it gets hotter these
insects want to come inside where it is
cooler and that is why you need dynatrap
dinotrap is the leading manufacturer now
the outdoor mosquito and insect traps
and now they've just created the indoor
dynatrap fly light the fly that looks
like a subtle nightlight it plugs into
any indoor outlet and the dynatrap fly
light works day and night to attract and
trap flies mosquitoes and other pesky
insects and it definitely definitely
works we were getting sort of all the
bugs coming in during the summer and I
have a couple of Dino traps I put them
around my house the palatial Shapiro
estate and really took care of the bug
problem right quick I've been using that
dynatrap fly light for a couple of days
now and it is pretty insane how many
flies are actually in your house that
you have not really thought about but
you will find them now now that you have
the dynatrap there is nothing more
embarrassing and gross looking than you
have people over for dinner and there's
a bunch of flies buzzing around so
instead get down and trap go to dy na t
ra P comm dynatrap comm and enter promo
code daily wire and receive 15% off any
of their products again that's dynatrap
comm dy na t ra p comm and enter that
promo code daily wire and you receive
15% of any of their products dynatrap is
the safe silent simple solution to
household insect control go check it out
today
ok so meanwhile in a piece of it not so
great news for President Trump on his
birthday the New York Attorney General
who is wildly anti Trump wildly
anti-republican right the New York
Attorney General is so anti Trump and
anti Republican that after dinesh
d'souza was given a pardon you recall
the New York Attorney General's Office
stumped for an end to quote-unquote
double jeopardy rules that allowed
dinesh d'souza to escape ok the whole
point of a double jeopardy rule is that
once you've been pardoned you've been
pardoned or if you're acquitted you're
acquitted we don't get to try you twice
for the same crime the New York Attorney
General's Office said we should create
state laws that allow us to try you
twice for the same crime which is
idiotic so it's a very very biased New
York Attorney General's Office however
they did unveil a lawsuit against the
Trump foundation they are now calling
for the Trump foundation to be forcibly
shut down the lawsuit was also launched
against President Trump Donald Trump jr.
Ivanka Trump
erich fromm their accusation is that the
Trump campaign used the Trump foundation
itself as a goody bag for various
political purposes so according to the
New York Attorney General their
investigation found that the Trump
foundation raised in excess of 2.8
million dollars in a manner designed to
influence the 2016 presidential election
at the direction and under the control
of senior leadership of the Trump
presidential campaign they say that in
violation of state and federal law
senior Trump campaign staff including
campaign manager Corey Lewandowski
dictated the timing amounts and
recipients of grants by the foundation
to nonprofits and then they include for
example an email from Corey Lewandowski
to the head of the Trump Foundation
saying Allan is there any way that we
can make some disbursements this week
while we are in Iowa specifically on
Saturday meaning it's in the middle of
the campaign can we make some foundation
charitable contributions in Iowa because
we're in the middle of the campaign
right that's pretty damning stuff and
that is not useful to to the Trump
Foundation's claims of objectivity and
in separation now so I think these
charges are being wildly over publicized
yes do I think that these charges are
also somewhat selective in the in the
way that charities run yes and I'll
explain that in in just a couple of
moments but the New York Attorney
General's Office continues the Trump
Foundation also entered into at least
five self-dealing transactions that were
unlawful because they benefited mr.
Trump or businesses that he controls
they say these include $100,000 payment
to settle legal claims against mr.
Trump's mar-a-lago resort one hundred
and fifty eight thousand dollars to
settle legal claims against trump
National Golf Club and ten thousand
dollars to purchase a painting of mr.
Trump displayed at the Trump national
Doral all these are taking a little out
of context and might explain them in a
second in light of this misconduct and
total lack of oversight we are also
suing to dissolve the Trump foundation
under court supervision and barred
Donald Trump and other members of the
trem Foundation board of directors from
serving on the board of any other New
York charity now does this seem overly
harsh it does I'm gonna explain why
right now so the investigation into the
Trump foundation was launched in the
middle of the campaign in June 2016 what
caused this investigation to be launched
well in January President Trump decided
that he was going to skip a Fox News
Channel presidential debate you remember
this megyn kelly did a debate and he
didn't like the answer the questions
that he was being asked during that
debate and so President Trump decided to
skip that debate instead he counts a
program that I made with a charity event
for fun a charity fundraiser for
veterans right and the AG's office
claims that this event was not designed
to raise money for charity but to
benefit Trump politically
they say it was quote a trump campaign
event in which the foundation
participated the event was planned by
the campaign allegedly with
administrative assistance from the
foundation the real problem began when
the foundation ceded control over the
charitable funds it raised to senior
Trump campaign staff who dictated the
manner in which the foundation would
disperse those proceeds directed the
timing amounts and recipients of the
grants Trump used checks from photo ops
with his presidential campaign slogan on
the checks for example I can act you can
actually see their you know pictures of
President Trump holding these giant blow
up checks $100,000 to a veteran's group
and on the bottom it says Trump make
America great again so it's a foundation
being used for political purposes by the
Trump campaign now a lot of people on
the right are immediately going to
flashback to the Clinton Foundation and
the idea the Clinton Foundation was
basically a pass-through for the
Clintons that if you gave Hillary
Clinton's Foundation a bunch of money
suddenly you got a meeting with the
State Department or if you were warm
with the Clinton Foundation suddenly the
State Department Hillary Clinton they
they were pretty warm toward allowing
the State Department to make deals with
with your particular company in a
foreign country or they start pushing
particular policy and you would be right
to be concerned about this and you would
be right to wonder did the New York
Attorney General's Office ever do a
similar investigation of the Clinton
Foundation and the answer is probably
not now this is not what about ISM
because if the Trump Foundation violated
the law which it appears they have in
some ways then they will be punished and
they will be fined but it is also
important to note that political bias in
the New York AG's office has been rife
for years but whether it's eliot spitzer
or there was eric schneiderman or
whether it is the current New York
Attorney General this is an office that
has been used for vindictive political
purposes by a bunch of Democrats for a
very very long time and I find it highly
suspicious that they say the term
Foundation was acting badly for 25 years
for 30 years and yet only during the
campaign did they see fit to launch an
investigation to the front foundation
you want to talk about a ginned up
investigation that looks like it now
again does that mean that the Trump
Foundation didn't act illegally no it
looks like the term Foundation didactic
legally so for example Donald Trump
personally directed foundation funds to
be used to settle a lawsuit related to
mar-a-lago so Mara Lago was sued in 2006
for some sort of zoning violation and
they were ordered to give a hundred
thousand dollars to charity and Trump
instead of signing out of his pocket a
hundred thousand dollars to charity told
his foundation to give a hundred
thousand dollars to a different charity
now you know is that really all that
corrupts considering that Trump
supposedly gives a fair bit of money to
his own foundation well I mean again if
you
money to his foundation and then the and
then he tells his foundation to give
money to another foundation in the end
charities receiving the money right the
same thing is true in Iowa right in Iowa
there's a lot of complaints about he was
doing this for political purposes which
is probably correct did the veterans
receive the money or do they not receive
the money I mean they apparently
received the money there were complaints
for a long time they were not going to
receive the money now again it is also
worth noting here that prosecutions of
charities tend to be very selective so
I've worked with a number of 500 series
violation of the law and 501 C 3 s is
rife okay it is rife 501 C 3 s are
loosely handled they are they are
generally handled with with not the
proper amounts of care
major board organizations you know
organizations that have a hundred
million dollars in bank two hundred
million dollars in the bank these are
run really in accordance with the law
because they can't afford an audit but a
lot of smaller organizations like the
Trump Foundation run sort of haphazardly
and conveniently and it's easy for
people to get caught up in the haphazard
and convenience of it and they just use
it how they want to use it and then
there's violation of the law does this
mean that Trump is deeply corrupt
something horrible happened here all of
the payments that were made from the
Trump foundation were made to other
charities on behalf of Donald Trump and
the Trump foundation so do I think this
is the end of the world for President
Trump I don't
is it a prosecution that has some legs
yeah it probably does I mean it'll
probably stands up in court it is just
worthwhile noting that the New York AG's
office seems rather they seem rather
pumped up about this investigation as
opposed to other investigations of
charities that they have done before
again if these same allegations were
made about the Clinton Foundation I
assume people on the right would be
fully up in arms but I also think that
you know it is worth looking at the
extent of the violations here in the
extensive the violations here does not
appear to me to be supremely great we're
talking about ten hundred thousand
dollars here and there and again money
given from one charity to another
charity yes for Trump's personal benefit
but unfortunately I know too much about
charities to be particularly perturbed
about this this set of charges okay
meanwhile President Trump continues to
to push forward on the North Korean
summit and the and the after-effects of
that we'll talk about that in just a
second but first I want to talk about
your target practice okay so the fact is
you probably don't go to the range often
enough okay forty-two percent of
American households have a firearm with
three and five receiving formal firearms
training but an even smaller percentage
of regularly practice with the weapon
they would use an
self-defense situation my wife and I we
don't go to the range all that much
right we own a 9-millimeter and we want
a shotgun and we don't go to the range
all that much because we have two kids
who has time to go to the range well
that means that if you're not practicing
and probably getting to be a war shot
right you're not keeping up with the
times and that is why I target exists
also a most expensive and we go to
arrange it gets really expensive well so
there's something called the AI target
Pro the AI target Pro is the coolest
most fun thing so here is what it is
they use your actual gun so you can
become proficient with the firearm you
are actually going to use in real life
you use your smartphone and the
proprietary app uses a laser in place of
the bullet and will detect exactly where
your shots are land in the way that it
works is you have something that looks
like a bullet actually has a laser
inside you load it into the chamber of
the gun so that it is firing directly
down the line of where you are firing
and then you're essentially firing at a
screen your phone can pick it up and
evaluate exactly how you were doing in
terms of your shooting so you can
practice home defense
you can test different angles you can
Mack to maximize your tactical advantage
in your own home and you can do it with
your personal firearm so you get more
and more familiar with a firearm that
God forbidden it in an emergency
situation you might have to use right
now you can save 10% with the offer code
Shapiro when you purchase the I target
pro system I'm using it I'm gonna get my
wife to use it as well and it is
supremely easy to setup I mean very easy
to setup and very easy to use you can
save money time take your skill to the
next level safely and effectively there
are folks in our office who are
legitimate like target shooting
champions and they use AI target Pro at
home that is the letter I to AI
target procom use promo code Shapiro and
save 10% what the offer code Shapiro
when you purchase the AI target pro
system it's a lot of fun it's really
cool it'll make your shooting better and
it is safe I mean it's you're not firing
anything so it's absolutely safe
alrighty so meanwhile President Trump
continues to forge ahead with this North
Korean summit fallout and I want to talk
a little bit about what president
Trump's goals are with regard to North
Korea so there's been a lot of talk
about denuclearization is that really
Trump's goal is that really something
that is going to happen here I do not
think that this is Trump's goal I do not
think the denuclearization is something
that's actually going to happen because
I think if you're kim jeong-hoon you'd
have to be a to give up your nukes
now your nukes are what brought you to
the table your nukes are what made
everybody pay attention to you your
nuclear program over the past 30 years
has allowed you to be bribed by the west
over and over and over what this really
is if we were really gonna be honest
about this what this really is is Trump
attempting to do what Nixon did when
Nixon went to China opening up China
liberal
in China turning China from a one-party
dictatorship that was repressive in
extraordinary amounts against his people
and militaristic as well into a still
militaristic still repressive regime but
less than it was I think that's the idea
here turning North Korea into Vietnam
right turning a threatening communist
country into a slightly less threatening
communist country if that were the
actual goal here the stated goal here
and then you'd sort of understand what
Trump is doing a little bit better than
the claims that North Korea has become a
non threat or that they are going to
denuclearize I don't think any of that
is going to happen it is also worth
stating that president tack the
president comes tactics here something
new now we're not gonna know whether the
tactics are good or bad until we have
the effect of the tactic we're not going
to know whether or not this is effective
until we find out what exactly Kim
jong-un is willing to give up but the
president is taking a very high risk
tactic here and his high-risk tactic is
that he's going to flatter Kim jong-un
into liking him he's gonna flatter Kim
jong-un into believing he can be part of
the family of Nations I'm not a big
believer in this tactic I wasn't a big
believer in this tactic when President
Trump did it with Iran well I mean when
President Obama did it with him Iran
when he said these are the moderates the
mullahs that we're gonna put them aside
the moderates in Iran will be elevated
by involvement in the world economy
global is a the the the hilarity of this
sort of position actually is that
President Trump's position he's very
anti-globalist but he's essentially
saying globalization integration into
the world economy is gonna make North
Korea more moderate and hey sure I guess
worth a shot we've been trying this for
for several decades and it's not
actually working so maybe something
different is called for and new with
that said there is another question and
that is how far does Trump have to go in
order to try to integrate Kim Jong Un's
of the world economy does he actually
does he actually have to praise him to
the skies the way that he has been doing
because some of the stuff the president
Trump has been saying is is just I mean
there's no other way to put it tomorrow
okay so what was so president Trump was
asked by Bret Baier about the North
Korean dictator and here's what
President Trump had to say about Kim
jong-un you were asked in the press
conference a number of different times
in different ways about human rights and
you know that you called this
relationship really good and that he
very talented person you know you call
people sometimes killers he know he is a
killer
he's clearly is executing people hey
when you take over a country tough
country tough people and you take it
over from your father I don't care who
you are what you are how much of an
advantage you have if you could do that
at 27 years old you I mean that's one in
10,000 that could do that so he's a very
smart guy he's a great negotiator but I
think we understand each other
but him he still some done some really
bad things yeah but so have a lot of
other people done some really bad things
I mean I could go through a lot of
nation's where a lot of bad things were
done now look with all of that being
said yes okay so he says yes he's done
some really bad things but a lot of
other nations are doing really bad
things and then he says that you know
only one in 10,000 people could have
taken over a country twenty-seven not
true there are plenty of dictators who
have hands it over to their sons but in
any case the question is why would
President Trump do this because let's
look at the reality of North Korea North
Korea isn't just any other place in
North Korea is the worst place to live
maybe on planet Earth okay here is some
testimony of a North Korean survivor who
escaped ok here's what it's like to be
in North Korea the country every night
someone tries to escape or someone
doesn't obey their orders somebody who's
in the gulags for that they strip you
naked and start the beat up they beat
you all night long every night when the
lights go out it's time to sleep but
from every room there are sounds sounds
of beatings I mean North Korea is an
awful awful awful place and the
president doesn't have to make light of
that in order to in order to get Kim
jong-un to the table it's not necessary
now does that mean that president Trump
doesn't actually recognized the evils of
Kim jong-un
I don't think so I mean I think that
President Trump just has a sneaking I
think President Trump operates in one of
two modes either he hates you or he
loves you I don't think there's a lot of
in-between with President Trump as a
human being I think the president Trump
either hates you and then he gives you a
nickname on Twitter or he loves you in
which case you are the greatest person
who ever was so he has the best
relationships right when he was at the
g7 like three days ago when he evaluated
his relationships with the other people
at the g7 on a scale of one to ten it
was a ten but there is no five and
president Trump scale right it is either
a 1 or a 10 so it went from a 10 to a 1
in the space of about 25 seconds as soon
as Justin Trudeau said something that
Trump didn't like then I went to a 1
right then Justin Trudeau was a cheat
and a liar
right now kim jeong-hoon is a wonderful
dude but the minute Kim jong-un screws
president Trump then presumably he
becomes a cheat and wire a little Rocket
Man again you know there's something to
the idea that President Trump does have
the capacity to swivel on a dime and so
Kim jong-un does not fulfill his oaths
here than president Trump swivels on him
but still there there's something deep
wrong about saying that a man who has 25
million people in abject slavery in a
slave state and 200,000 people in gulags
there are lots of people who said now
again the reason that I'm not taking it
a little bit more seriously in terms of
you know President Trump specifically
praising Kim is because he says this
crap about everybody so in the same
exact interview he was asked about josh
Jinping Chou Jinping is the leader of
China
he's the dictator of China and here's
President Trump speaking warmly about
the fact that jumping is now president
for life incredible guy they just
essentially president for life pretty
good well it's not pretty good he's the
head of the Communist Party there's no
democracy in China it's not pretty good
music saying moammar qaddafi he's been
president there for like 30 years pretty
good Saddam Hussein been there for a
long time pretty good no of course it's
not pretty good but the the predicate to
his answer about President Xi is that he
thinks that President Xi is a good guy
so President Xi's a good guy than
everything that he does is good and
president from did did exactly the same
sort of thing with regard to Vladimir
Putin you'll remember during the
election cycle who's asked by Bill
O'Reilly that Vladimir Putin's a killer
and Trump said well we kill lots of
people too now this is president Trump's
version of realpolitik his version of
real politics that will not allow to
call anybody out morally because
everybody on the world stage is dirty
and there's basically just a set of
competing interests morality doesn't
really take a leading role here it's
instead us in a hard-hearted and
gimlet-eyed fashion determining what
America's interests are right now our
interests are in trying to woo North
Korea and that means that we have to be
really really nice to North Korea I have
problems with this particular approach
which I will explain in just second
first we're gonna have to go for Daily
wire calm to subscribe so for $9.99 a
month you get the rest of my show live
you get the rest of clayvin show live
the rest of Noel's show live and you can
ask me questions when you are a
subscriber for $99 a year you get the
annual subscription that comes along
with the leftist tears hot or cold
tumblr the very finest in all beverage
vessels we are traveling today so I
brought my invisible beverage vessel it
is incredible I mean when you travel it
disappears maybe it doesn't but I won't
tell you it's a secret in any case the
the fact is that when you become a
subscriber you also get to you also get
to send us questions and we do have an
episode of the conversation coming up
next week where I will answer your
questions for the entire hour so you can
send in your questions when you go over
to the conversation page and enter those
questions there when you're a subscriber
everybody can watch but only
drivers get to ask and their questions
and have those questions answered also
go over to iTunes please go over to
YouTube and subscribe we have a Sunday
special that is coming up starring
Michael Shermer the editor of skeptic
magazine we talk about God in atheism
he's a militant agnostic / atheist and I
of course am a very religious human and
so we will have a conversation all about
religion and God and freewill and
politics it's really fascinating I think
you'll really enjoy it so go check that
out we're the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
so the going perspective seems to be
that when President Trump says stuff
it's just him saying stuff so if
president from says nice stuff about
Putin yesterday whatever he says stuff
because as I've said before he's a dude
who says a lot of stuff you know
president Trump says many a thing and I
mean that could frankly go on his
epitaph I mean well you know after 120
years when the president when the
president finally has a gravestone then
you know it will it could say on in
Donald Trump the man said a lot of
things okay because that's president
from shake and I think everybody in the
United States has learned to discount
these things but on the international
stage people don't automatically
discount what it is that you are saying
they take what you were saying a lot
more seriously and so when President
Trump starts praising dictators it gives
dictators a feeling they can get away
with things and the way that you know
this is that Barack Obama did exactly
the same thing with Iran and Iran
proceeded to get away with things Barack
Obama did the same thing with Vladimir
Putin Putin proceeded to get away with
things George HW Bush by the way did the
same thing with Putin when he said that
he looked into pooty pooty eyes and he
saw his soul and then Vladimir Putin
promptly decided that he was going to
invade Georgia right the neighboring
country of Georgia hey that that the
dictators bad people aggressive people
they tend to react to warmth as though
that warmth is a sign of weakness I like
too much better when President Trump was
being aggressive now here's something
that I'll point out if you were very
family font of when President Trump was
being aggressive I'm not sure how you
are very fond of when he is not being
aggressive anymore I mean to the extent
that he's not being aggressive so for
example President Trump when when he was
meeting with Kim trouble in this video
just came out it was revealed actually
by the by the North Korean media which
is just wonderful and it is a picture of
President Trump saluting a North Korean
general right now you recall when when
President Obama bowed before the Saudi
kings and everybody went nuts right I
was one of the people who said like what
the hell is this when President Obama
bowed to I think as the Japanese
president Japanese premier and everybody
went nuts like why is he running around
the world kowtow into people
well here's the President of the United
States who instead of shaking the hand
of this North Korean general is going up
for the salute like you shouldn't be
saluting generals of Tim Pok
dictatorships who keep their people in
abject poverty and slavery that's it's
not a good idea now again the under the
the argument is that this is all
pragmatism
then in the end moral signaling doesn't
matter I don't think that's true the
reason I don't think that's true is
because one of the things that helped
bring down the Soviet Union
it was the fact that we had something
called Voice of America in Europe for
folks not all that familiar with the
history but something called Voice of
America in Europe in the Soviet Union
you were forbidden from listening to
Western media you could not get Western
media you couldn't see Western papers
you can listen to Western radio so we
had basically bootlegged radios into the
Eastern Bloc into the Soviet bloc and
then we would broadcast Voice of America
and we would talk about how Great
America was and how terrible
Soviet Russia was and how Soviet Russia
was repressing you and if it weren't for
Soviet Russia your life would be so much
better part of that was designed to let
people on the other side know that we
were on their side right to let people
who were living under this dictatorship
know that we are on their side if you're
in North Korea there are a lot of
bootleg radios in there and a lot of
like pieces of technology in North Korea
wouldn't be good to know that the
President of the United States is not
fomenting your dictatorship that the
President of the United States is trying
to weaken that dictatorship now the
president can't openly say that but at
the very least the president shouldn't
be praising the dictator it does have an
impact on the people who are living
inside the country it also has an impact
on the other countries in the region
which are now being told essentially
that they should not isolate North Korea
any longer they should preemptively D
isolate North Korea and this is somehow
going to fix things now I guess the
question is what do you think is the
most realistic possible outcome here if
you think the most realistic possible
outcome is the liberalization of North
Korea into a quasi China state then
maybe all of this works out even so I'm
not sure why you need the the fawning
language from President Trump even
though I don't think president Trump
means it I think President Trump as I
said this is how he negotiates he
flatters you in flatters he flatters you
until you say no which point clubs you
but but if your goal here is sort of the
liberalisation of North Korea I gotta I
gotta admit I'm not a huge fan of this
grand strategy typically I understand
the strategy maybe maybe it's the best
strategy that's available but I'm not a
huge fan the reason I'm not a huge fan
is because I'm not sure that Nixon made
the right decision in actually
liberalizing China because I'm not sure
China was liberalized right China is me
more powerful threat on the world stage
today than they were in 1970 in 1970
they were a poor rogue state run by Mao
Zedong who had murdered 40 million of
his own people and we proceeded to
engage in tremendous amount of commerce
with them that may have liberalized
their economy and may have gotten some
people out of poverty which all of which
is good but the Communist Party is still
running the place as a repressive
dictatorship
maybe the better strategy would have
been to do to China exact what we did to
the Soviet Union which is you cut them
off at the knees
you you are belligerent you build up
your arms you suggest that you're not
going to allow them to expand their
sphere of influence and then you wait
for them to collapse from with it maybe
it turns out that by giving money to
dictatorships you're actually
strengthening the dictatorships I see
the arguments both ways I'm not gonna
say that my argument is dispositive or
that my argument is is the only one
that's being made and maybe president
Trump is totally right and I'm totally
wrong on all this time will tell I will
say however I do not think that it is
appropriate or decent for the President
of the United States to speak to the way
that President Trump does about
dictators even though I get it he's
president Trump and he says this kind of
stuff about virtually everybody okay so
meanwhile and the media has been
responding to President Trump's
criticism president Truong has been
going after the media he tweeted out the
other day that the worst enemy of the
United States were the mainstream media
a statement which I I agree with that
the media are a problem I think that we
have worse enemies than Wolf Blitzer I
just I think the kim jeong-hoon is a
worse enemy to the United States than
like Jake Tapper
but Wolf Blitzer the fact that the media
feel the need to defend really
demonstrates why the media are blowing
it so here's Wolf Blitzer trying to
explain that he is not your worst enemy
a lot of his supporters believe that we
are the enemy of the American people and
that is a really really an awful
situation we are not the enemy of the
American people we love the American
people if you have to assure people that
you love them that means that you
haven't done a good job right if I have
to constantly be reassuring my wife then
I'm not her enemy that I love her our
marriage will end very soon okay so it's
good to say I love you to your wife
unsolicited all right it's good to
demonstrate your love to your wife
unsolicited
but if your wife says you're a jerk and
you hate me and you're garbage and you
say no honey I'm not I don't hate you I
love you is that really an effective
tactic it turns out that probably you've
blown a lot of your credibility already
the reality is that the media have have
blown their credibility in a pretty
significant way over and over and over
and president Trump when he picks on the
media all he's really doing is
signifying to them once again that that
they do not have the trust of the
American people the only way they're
gonna win back the trust of the American
people is to cover things in an
objective fashion which apparently they
refuse to do okay meanwhile party
infighting is breaking out on both sides
of the aisle the Republican Party is
having an
going gun battle between the the
so-called establishment the so-called
anti-establishment I find this battles
sort of confusing in the sense that
Trump is the establishment he's the
President of the United States he's the
most powerful man on planet earth and
the idea that if you don't like some of
his policies that somehow you're now
pro-establishment is bizarre to me you
know I always defined establishment
there's this fungibility about some of
the political language that I find
deeply stupid so here for example when
people say establishment I always took
establishment to mean too willing to
work with the other side to conciliatory
to willing to promote leftist policies
not in alignment with conservative
values that was establishments made
that's how I always took establishment I
didn't take establishment to mean you
know anti X politician because that's
just weird that's not what establishment
means but it seems like establishment
has been turned into an an all-purpose
club to wield against virtually anybody
so for example Corey Stewart he says
that his victory in the in the
Republican primaries in Virginia shows
that the establishment is going the way
of the dodo bird Corey Stewart probably
will lose to Tim Kaine in Virginia he
has a long history of hobnobbing with
with sort of all trite figures a lot a
lot of Republican Party politicians are
not in love with Corey Stewart for I
think a lot of very good reasons here's
Corey Stewart saying the establishment
is going the way of the dodo bird it's a
Republican establishment once they you
know continue to oppose to oppose the
president myself and others who support
them on those things are going to go the
way of the dodo they're going to
disappear and rising a part of the
Republican Party is the trunk
established and sorry the the Trump
support the Trump base that's what's
taking over and that's me the new
Republican Party they the old yard the
establishment can either get on board or
they're going to have to get out
okay the establishment is Trump okay
Trump runs the party he runs it with a
pretty iron hand okay Ron oh the the
head of the GOP right the head of the
RNC is a Romney McDaniel right Rhonda
Rhonda McGraw
Romney McDaniel and she came out the
statement yesterday right she actually
tweeted out in pretty incredible terms I
don't know I want to find her exact
weight so that I can read it to you
because it's pretty astonishing so
Rhonda McDaniel who you'll recall
actually used to call herself around a
Romney McDaniel men Trump asked her not
to use her
maiden name Romney because he found it
insulting and so she and so she just
changed it on behalf of the President to
the United States which if that doesn't
show you the power of President Trump
I'm not sure what does she tweeted this
out yesterday she tweeted out here it is
sorry let me grab it she tweeted out
that if you do not follow President
Trump
complacency is our enemy anyone that
does not embrace the donald trump agenda
of making America great again will be
making a mistake anyone who doesn't
embrace the the trumpet listen I love a
lot of the Trump agenda I think a lot of
the Trump agenda is just great I've been
very very positive about president in
Trump's political agenda for the last
year and a half I've said that I think
that it's the most conservative
year-and-a-half of governance I've ever
seen but I'm not a fan of this whole you
know Donald Trump is is the king and we
must all bow before him because I'm not
the fan of doing that with any
politician I think we ought to praise
him when he does something good we ought
to criticize him when he does something
bad but if the idea is that he is not
the establishment I'm not sure where you
are getting that so we have all of these
terms that have now been twisted to mean
whatever people want them to mean so
that's the fight inside the Republican
Party meanwhile the Democrats continue
to be as stupid as they possibly can a
Democratic candidate has now run one of
the most painful and yet hilarious
campaign ads in history the Democratic
candidate for the House of
Representatives in Colorado's name is
Levi Tillman he's run against Jason crow
he says that he says that the best way
to stop school shootings is to armed
schools and teachers with pepper spray
and in his campaign ad he sprays himself
with pepper spray to show how effective
this strategy would be I'm calling on
Congress to stop talking past each other
and try something new
empower schools and teachers with
non-lethal self-defense tools like this
can of pepper spray
this will stop anyone in their tracks
and then he sprays himself in the eyes
with pepper spray and then he has to
dunk his head in vats of chemicals to
stop it and then he described how
terrible is is there's more than 300
million guns in the United States as
this guy's now soaked in soap I'll go to
the for kids in community not Washington
insiders operations and I was running a
hose over his eyes non-lethal school
defense is part of the solution
I hope the Democrats continue to run on
these platforms forever and never stop
doing it all Democrats please spray
pepper spray in your eyes to own the own
the cons my goodness gracious
so never problems we're having inside
the Republican Party at least we're not
spraying ourselves in the face with
pepper spray in or demonstrate that our
agenda is apparently superior
well done Rando Colorado Democrat my
goodness I mean it's almost literally
cutting off your nose to spite your face
it's literally blinding yourself in
order to demonstrate that President
Trump is wrong about guns well just
pretty amazing stuff okay time for some
things I like and then some things that
I hate so the thing I like today I was
on a plane yesterday because I'm doing
my show from Dallas today where I'm
speaking of CPUSA events and and I was
able to watch a movie called the death
of Stalin now I will admit when I saw
the preview for death of Stalin
I was not necessarily enthralled because
I thought this is gonna make light of
the Soviet Union I thought that what it
was going to do was it was going to make
light of one of the most monstrous
regimes in the history of the world and
instead instead the movie is spectacular
I think it is the best movie that's been
made in maybe the last five years it
really is that good here's a little bit
of the preview
[Music]
our general secretary is lying in a
puddle of indignity he's feeling a well
clearly
I want to make a speech my father's
funeral but no problem technically yes
but practically when I said no problem
what I meant was no problem ignore me
Stalin would have wanted the committee
as well all those in favor
Thierry okay so the preview makes it
look like just an outright comedy the
the opening scene of the the opening
scene of the film like the first three
minutes of the film is taking place at a
concert where Stalin calls the the head
that the person who is the head of the
the radio broadcasting facility and
they're playing a Mozart piano concerto
and he calls up the guy and then he says
I want a recording of this and it turns
out the guy has not been recording it
and so he forces everybody back into the
theatre essentially at gunpoint and then
makes them replay the entire concerto
and applaud because he doesn't want to
be shot by Stalin I mean the opening
scene of this is Stalin with all of his
cronies handing out death lists and
people being dragged out of their
apartments and shot so the the comedy is
that mean is a darker than dark comedy
and the whole point of this is that
everybody who is there was just an evil
evil him being these were evil human
beings and that the cult of personality
is really dangerous if you want to
understand what North Korea really looks
like then this is actually a pretty good
indicator right better than sort of the
overt silly comedy of Team America you
wanna know what North Korea really looks
like watch the death of style and that's
probably what more of Korea is is most
like the movie is tremendous I can't
recommend it highly enough all the
performances are just terrific and I
mean well they did not pull their
punches I mean this movie does not pull
its punches what what it what a terrific
film so go check that out the death of
Stalin I believe it's available on
Amazon right now ok time for a couple of
things that I hate
okay so nature magazine right which is
one of the most prominent and
prestigious journals in science has now
run an editorial calling for diversity
in science why you might ask do the skin
colors and sexual orientations of
scientists matter aren't we mostly
interested in the objective verifiable
and replicable results of experiments no
shut up you bigot what we're mostly
interested in is whether you're doctors
black or not that's what we're really
interested in so the editorial says lab
groups departments universities and
national funders should encourage
participation in science from as many
sectors of the population as possible
it's the right thing to do both morally
and to help build a sustainable future
for research that truly represents
society listen I'm fine with more
scientists of all ilk we need more
scientists we need more people who know
what they are doing and researching and
making the world a better place but then
they say this okay that remember this is
in a science journal quote a more
representative work force is more likely
to pursue questions and problems that go
beyond the narrow slice of humanity that
much of science is currently set up to
serve so in other words if you have a
black set of researchers that are going
to research different questions than
white researchers did they present any
evidence for this whatsoever of course
not
here's their example widening the focus
is essential if publicly funded research
is to protect and preserve its mandate
to work to improve society for example a
high proportion of the research that
comes out of the Western world uses
tissue and blood from white individuals
to screen drugs and therapies for a
diverse population yet it is well known
that people from different ethnic groups
have different susceptibility to some
diseases okay that's idiotic what you're
now suggesting really is that we should
take into account more minority groups
when we do the research into tissues and
blood samples but that doesn't say you
need a black doctor to do it and that's
like saying that we need more dog and
dog is used in experiments than rats
used in experiments and we need more dog
doctors i what what what again this is a
scientific journal and has nothing to do
with with anything but science has gone
by the wayside and the truth is that a
lot of science is just not real okay so
the best example of this that I can talk
about today is there's this fascinating
fascinating story when something called
the Zimbardo the Zimbardo experiment
it's called the Stanford Prison
Experiment you probably heard of it if
you took psychology 101 in college you
know about this in Bardo experiment what
it was is tilt the sky philip zimbardo
is in the early 60s I believe he took a
group of volunteers and he separated
them into prisoners and guards and then
supposedly what happened is that the
guards just by being labeled
guards and the prisoners by virtue of
being prisoners the guard started
basically torturing the prisoners and
after six days they'd shut down the
experiment because the guards had become
vicious brutal horrible guards and the
prisoners had been tortured you know
beyond the pale well it turns out the
entire experiment was a fraud according
to an article at medium from that in Ben
bloom this was all nonsense basically
the people who are acting as the
prisoners say they faked their
breakdowns for the cameras that they
were that they were shouting and
screaming and protesting because it was
all not real and the guards themselves
were being told by the scientists in
charge that they needed to act as brutal
as humanly possible so for example one
of the guards a guy named Ava Schulman
explained quote I took it as kind of an
improv exercise I believed that I was
doing what the researchers wanted me to
do and I thought I'd do it better than
anybody else by creating this despicable
guard persona I'd never been to the
south but I used a southern accent which
I got from Cool Hand Luke
so Zimbardo lied about all of this he
did before Congress actually he
testified before Congress at the request
of the House Committee on the judiciary
and he said the guards were quote simply
told that they were going to go into a
situation that could be serious and have
some danger they made up their own rules
for maintaining law order in respect
this is untrue he told them exactly how
to act his grad students told them
exactly how to act now the reason this
experiment was supposedly important is
because what it supposedly taught you is
that just as a normal human being you
wore a sadist right you were put in the
right situation you would have become a
Nazi camp guard and force people into
the chambers that is not true okay what
this experiment actually suggests and
what similar experiments like the famous
Milgram experiment suggest is that human
beings in order to be brutal have to buy
into an idea of a higher good which they
are serving if you that we tend to treat
each other as ends in normal individual
life right when we meet each other on
the street but when we have a higher
purpose
depending on what that higher purpose is
we start treating each other as means or
obstacles to that end which is really
really dangerous stuff and the Milgram
experiment which is sort of similar as
an experiment where again scientists
brought in a group of volunteers and
then they separated them into two groups
one was going to be the subjects of an
experiment and one was one with the
experimenter now what the people in the
volunteer group didn't know is that
everybody who was selected to be the
volunteer group for the for the
experiment the subjects of the
experiment all of those were actors who
had been hired by the experimenters and
the people who are supposed to be
testing those actors those were the
volunteers so the way that it works is
they would put the actors in a room and
then they would have the volunteers who
are now the experimenters turn a dial
that was supposedly sending a an
electrical shock to
the actors if they got questions wrong
and the scientists would stand over the
shoulders of the various people who are
administering the shocks and they would
say to them you know for the sake of
science we have to find out whether you
know if you if you torture people they
are going to give answers like if you
torture people they'll give better
answers they'll learn faster and even
when people are screaming and pleading
for help supposedly according to the
Milgram experiment people continue to
shock those people now the problem the
Milgram experiment was not replicable
there are a bunch of different groups
some of them like 70% of them would
shock people some of them 20% would
shock people or 10% or 5% it widely
varied how did it vary it depended how
many people in the group believed in the
usefulness of the experiments itself
believed in the value of the scientific
discovery being made in other words it's
going to be kind of difficult to get
people to be Nazi prison guards unless
they are Nazis it's kind of difficult to
get people to be Josef Mengele unless
they believe that they are forwarding
the cause of Nazi racial science so what
this means is be very careful about the
causes that you pick be very careful
about the tribe that you choose because
if you're not careful then you end up
treating people not as individuals but
as widgets that you can manipulate and
harm for whatever purpose is necessary
your own practical interests you not
outweigh the rights of others and do not
outweigh your the necessity to be decent
to individual human beings it's a
warning to everybody on all sides of the
aisle ok we will be back here tomorrow
with much much more I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Sonia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wha of era the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018
you